Це Тетяна, їй 19 років, вона студентка одного з київських вишів.
Катерині 31, вона працює в банку, а з 24 лютого займалася волонтерством.
На перший погляд цього не помітно, але обидві дівчини борються
зі шрамами, які залишила війна.
Ми з вами проходимо до будинку, де була моя родина під час вибуху,
коли з нами це все сталося.
Ми бачимо, що з нього залишилося. Одні руїни.
Усі дивуються, що ми залишилися живі. Я по цей день, як вийду десь прогулятися,
до мене може друг підійти: "Як ти залишилася жива, я по цей день
не можу знайти відповіді", кажу: "Я теж не знаю". І все.
Після повномасштабного вторгнення РФ Тетяна приїхала до батьків
у село Небелиця на Київщині. Коли росіяни підійшли впритул до села,
сім'я перебралася в будинок до родичів.
28 лютого російський снаряд упав поруч із їхньою оселею.
Я почула вибух десь далеко, і хочу сказати: "Ходімте, бо знов бахкає" -
і я нічого не встигла сказати. У мене уже просто йшла кров з лиця, і все.
І тільки чула на задньому фоні крики своєї мами: "Діти, ви де? Виходьте!"
Десятки дрібних осколків посікли обличчя Тетяни.
Ось так дівчина виглядала після того, як лікарі зашили рани.
Молодий лікар Андрій Васильєв був одним з перших, хто працював з пораненнями Тетяни.
Він - асистент пластичного хірурга, але в кінці лютого виїхав з Києва
і надавав допомогу пораненим у звичайній лікарні.
В обличчі були уламки скла. Уся ліва частина була посічена.
І вона дуже боялася, що втратила око. Але, дякувати Богу, цього не сталося.
Я її завжди заспокоював, що ми все зробимо, відновимо обличчя, буде все класно.
Але вона в це не вірила.
Насправді лікар і сам спершу сумнівався, що обличчя Тетяни
буде таким, як і раніше. Ось так дівчина виглядала вже через два місяці - у квітні.
На той момент я уже був більш впевнений, що результат буде більш-менш нормальним.
Самі шрами нормально затягнулися.
Дівчина стала учасницею програми NoScar - "Без шрамів".
Це ініціатива українських пластичних хірургів, які безкоштовно загоюють рубці
постраждалим від війни. До неї долучилися 40 лікарів з різних українських міст.
Сергій Королюк - один з них. Тетяна стала його першою пацієнткою зі слідами від війни.
У її випадку минулося без операцій.
Ми спочатку робили медикаментозні корекції, правильні перев'язки,
використання засобів для заживлення ран і рубців, і вже на останньому етапі
почали проводити хірургічні, лазерні коригування цих рубців.
Тетяна поставила собі за мету відновити обличчя до нового року.
Сумлінно виконувала поради лікарів, робила масажі обличчя.
Нині вона майже нічим не відрізняється від дівчини на фото в кімнаті.
Хіба стала дещо дорослішою.
Потрібно іти вперед, не дивлячись ні на що, і пам'ятати - ти в себе одна єдина,
що б не сталося, ти завжди була гарна і будеш гарна, не дивлячись,
які в тебе можуть бути травми. Люди, яким ти справді будеш потрібна,
вони будуть поруч з тобою, не дивлячись на те.
Люблять в першу чергу не за лице, а за те, яка ти людина.
Катерина 24 лютого виїхала з Києва до рідного Коростеня, там приєдналася
до місцевих волонтерів. Вони збирали спорядження для військових,
возили їжу на блокпости. Під час однієї з таких поїздок блокпост
атакував ворожий безпілотник.
Я якраз у цей момент говорила по телефону, буквально секунда -
я закриваю очі, відкриваю - я лежу на асфальті. Дикий писк у вухах.
Відкриваю очі - стоїть військовий, дивиться - напевне, він думав, що я мертва,
поки я не почала рухатися. У той момент вбило п'ять людей одразу на тому місці.
Мене просто врятувало диво і Бог, можна сказати, янгол-охоронець.
Я по-іншому це пояснити не можу.
Дівчина говорить, що спершу навіть не відчувала болю.
Насправді ж її тіло прошили уламки бетону.
Виходить, ось так навиліт пройшов осколок. Просто наскрізь.
Вхідний отвір і вихідний. Це місце зашивали, це воно найважче заживало.
На грудях було. Тут на руці лишився опік, шрам.
Так до восьми десь по тілу слідів лишилося.
Через такі сліди на тілі Катерина звернулася до лікарів, які працюють за ініціативою NoScar
і безкоштовно отримала допомогу. У червні їй провели операцію з корекції шрамів.
За рік шрами затягуються і біліють. Лазерна корекція майже повністю їх прибере.
Цю процедуру дівчина ще планує зробити.
Ти звикла до себе одної, до того, ти звикла себе бачити в дзеркалі одною.
А коли ти бачиш ці сліди, це психологічно повертає тебе іноді в той момент,
і ти розумієш, що ти вже нічого змінити не можеш. Але є можливість прибрати
ці шрами і психологічно тобі стає від цього легше.
Лікар Сергій Королюк готується оперувати ще одного постраждалого
через бойові дії - волонтера з Бородянки, якого поранило після "прильоту" міни.
Прибрати цей шрам і відновити по можливості м'язи, зробити таку пластику м'язів,
щоб вони виконували опорну функцію, захисну, бо, бачите, з цієї сторони рівно,
а тут така як гуля випирає.
Пластичний хірург уже консультує кілька десятків людей, травмованих війною.
У всіх є дещо спільне.
Коли вони отримали ці травми і десь незадоволені своїм зовнішнім виглядом,
у них виявляється така замкнутість.
Часом у спілкуванні з ними вони тримають таку дистанцію.
Але потім, коли вони бачать результати, то це трошки розгальмовується.
Лікарі не втрачають надії, що шрами війни можна загоїти.
Принаймні зовнішні.